hey my name is alvin and i love
chocolate chip cookies
i think chocolate chip cookies are some
of the world's greatest pleasures
perfectly crisp on the outside chewy on
the inside with large pockets of
chocolate
and when they're done right there is
nothing quite like i strongly believe
that you should be able to enjoy a
chocolate chip cookie any day of the
week so i'll be showing you guys
my personal recipes for a two minute two
hour and two day cooking
i think this is gonna be fun maybe you
only got two minutes and you want to
make a cookie
first thing we're gonna do we're gonna
take some softened butter
kind of get it in here this is more
about those times you get just cravings
and you don't want like 10 cookies but
you just want something sweet that'll
hit those spots
add in some brown sugar and then you
want to mix this
until it's essentially a smooth paste
so next is your wet ingredients you're
going to take your egg and your vanilla
and just kind of go in it's essentially
the same steps as making a normal
chocolate chip cookie except you're just
dealing with smaller amounts
i didn't say this was going to be the
easiest thing to make but
it beats having to whisk a whole giant
bowl of this stuff
after that flour no matter how many
times i make chocolate chip cookies
i always end up spilling go in with some
salt and some chocolate chips
you actually want to save a handful
because we're going to
decorate the top of the cookie to have
more chocolate on top so
let's go inside it looks like
chocolate chip cookie dough that's
because it is
oh yeah you want a plate that is pretty
large like a normal dinner plate
some parchment as well because the
parchment is going to help prevent the
cookie from sticking
and we're going to scoop a nice big
scoop of cookie dough because
man stuff's good all right
kind of like that you also want to
decorate the top with a little bit more
chocolate
and the key here is to actually clump
them together
when it starts to cook and you'll see
this it'll start to spread
it's like studying a watch with jewelry
except the diamonds
chocolate chips i'm going to say that
this cookie
contains a lot of the drip as i've heard
in some of the songs this is gonna go in
for about
a minute and 30 seconds and we're gonna
see how it goes
looks pretty nice he looks like a uh
nice old
chocolate chip cookie you know almost
like the clip art version
i'm gonna peel this off it's a nice
chewy little cookie we have over here
this is your two minute cookie
which is done in the microwave which i
think is pretty awesome
all right let's see what we got it's
nice and soft
good uh chocolate distribution
for a microwave cookie it's better than
you think
all right on to the two-hour cookie this
is a pretty uh standard chocolate chip
cookie recipe you can start with some
normal white sugar
some light brown sugar and a good amount
of salt
give these a nice whisk you know you
might have your own recipe
of a regular chocolate chip cookie your
grandma might have one
my grandma did not have a chocolate chip
cookie recipe because
she's chinese but i was like you know
what i want to make some friends
and in order to make friends i need to
give them food what kind of food does
everybody like
chocolate chip cookies so this is one of
my first recipes
i'm gonna go in delicious golden melted
butter
oh yeah making cookies not the easiest
thing in the world
but in the end i think it's all worth it
and with your liquids
got two old eggs
one and two and then
really good vanilla extract just want to
keep on going
until it's at that stage where you can
tell that it's like really whipped
all right that is beautiful and with the
dry ingredients
got some flour and some baking soda
we're just going to slowly fold i like
to take it slow
just because i think the slower and
smoother
it's better that's beautiful right there
probably one of my favorite parts about
chocolate chip cookies is
the chocolate moment of silence please
man i love that beautiful chocolate
chunks just
swimming and incorporating and just
evenly being dispersed
throughout the dough i might have put
too much chocolate then again
i like my chocolate chip cookies like i
like my bank account
freaking loaded whoa this might be my
new wallpaper
at this point it's pretty darn awesome
it does benefit from
some time in the fridge so this is going
to go in the fridge okay so it's been
about an hour and this has chilled
pretty nicely i have a half sheet tray
lined with parchment paper
i'm gonna scoop some nice little cookie
balls i like to be pretty generous
with my cookie scoops oh that's
beautiful
there's a good boy nice
we have five cookies on the tray
obviously things gonna make like
10 15 20 more so save this if you have
more friends
bake it if you don't have friends that's
kind of sad these are gonna go into an
oven at around 350 degrees to get a nice
crust on the outside to keep the inside
chewy so
we're gonna go uh bake these off
[Music]
yes look at these as you can see there
is a
nice sort of golden brown crust around
the outside but the inside
i can already tell it's like chewy it's
dense it's going to be delicious
oh yeah here we go and here we have it
a two hour chocolate chip cookie
nice caramelized crust on the outside
really chewy in the middle
super delicious here we go
that's nice dipping in milk
but the next one's gonna be even better
this is it this is the two
day cookie here we go so the first thing
we're gonna do
we're gonna make some toffee i'm going
to put in
a lot of butter into this pan after the
butter is going in you actually want to
also add in
light brown sugar and a good amount of
salt
i think it's important that you stir
pretty constantly throughout the process
because it helps the butter and the
sugar kind of stay together
this is a pretty personal recipe um i've
actually
been able to make a lot of my friends
due to this recipe
if you're watching if you've had one of
these cookies thank you for being my
friend
the butter and the sugar are coming
together pretty nicely
beautiful dark golden brown ribbons
happening right now
that's at 290. so that means uh this is
ready to come out so we got a nice tray
with parchment paper for the landing
this is probably one of my favorite
parts
i love it put it in the freezer as soon
as you can so
that's beautiful all right while the
toffee cools we're gonna make
some brown butter the first thing you
start with is a lot of butter
it's a lot of sticks don't worry you
know if someone asks how much butter one
of these cookies
don't let them watch this video so
butter is made of water
of milk salads and butter fat when
making brown butter the water
kind of melts off and evaporates and
that leaves the milk solids behind turn
golden brown
and that is because of something amazing
called the meyer reaction
we don't know what the miter reaction is
i don't know exactly either but it makes
stuff turn golden brown and it's
delicious
the milk solids are looking amazing your
average butter has around eighty percent
butter fat
sixteen percent water and three percent
milk solids we got two problems right
now
the water is gone and two this is really
hot so we try to put this and make
cookies right now would like burn
all the sugar cook the egg you know cook
the flour so there's a couple of
interesting solutions and one of them i
read online
in a lot of blogs is that they use ice
cubes you want to go really slow and add
one ice cube in at a time
and just wait for it it'll start to
bubble and it's cooling down the butter
it's adding back water into the mixture
all right dude we're gonna set you aside
but you smell great
got the rest of our ingredients brown
butter still just hanging out over there
what's up dude first um dark brown sugar
i think there's a lot of flavor in here
good old white sugar a lot of salt
actually i think that's one of the
secrets baking soda
and some espresso powder i think
espresso powder helps
knock back any of that fat or that sugar
that might be a little too much
the star ingredient of the show the
brown butter
is gonna be pretty dark compared to the
other ones that we've done before
but i think color is flavor four eggs go
in
a one two three
and four a lot of good
vanilla you really want to beat it until
smooth
dissolved mixture of almost like a
ribbon like consistency
[Music]
oh it's gonna be a good cookie all right
dubbing
in the flour slowly incorporate to these
beautiful ribbons of this butter and
sugar mix
that's a beautiful dough right there now
it's time to
add in the really good stuff let's go
get our chocolate and toffee
if you're spending two days to make a
chocolate cookie you're not doing it
justice unless you use
really really good chocolate so this is
some nice chocolate in bars and we're
just gonna go
in pretty large chunks this is one of
those things
where the less perfect it is the cooler
it is you're going to get a much more
texturally and visually interesting
cookie it's nicer when you have a
chocolate cookie has like
big pockets of chocolate everybody's
like oh you're like yeah i made that so
we're going to keep it like this
and let's go get the toffee so this is
what the toffee looks like
after about 30 minutes to an hour in the
freezer
make sure when you do this you don't
have any neighbors
and it's not 2 am they go into here
nice little ziploc bag squeeze out a
good amount
of the air
oh yeah i can't rap
these are broken down into toffee chunks
approximately the same size
as these over here these are going in
oh yeah don't waste any of this stuff on
the board either
that chocolate dust that's the good
stuff
let's get some gloves on get in there
with your hands i'm trying to make sure
the chocolate and the toffee
are both evenly distributed it's pretty
much ready so now i'm gonna go get a
tray and we can shape
he's into nice big cookie dough balls
pretty
generous amount almost the size of a
tennis ball but
we're gonna spend two days might as well
make a little bit bigger
probably wondering by now hey why is
this going to take two days so
this recipe specifically requires it to
rest for
36 hours but why 36 hours like why not
just like you know put it in the fridge
and just chill it until it's ready to go
well i actually worked at a bakery
before
there are chopstick cookies were the
best i've ever had
the reason why they were so good is
because the owner always rested it for
at least 36 hours what does it do you
know a lot of experts also say that the
resting process
allows flavors to intensify and
integrate more
with each other i'm no cookie scientist
but i baked one off right away
and i baked one off 36 hours later and
the one that i baked off 36 hours later
had more flavor the color was deeper it
was more caramelized
way better by a bile these are very soft
right now they need to rest so i'm going
to stir unwrap these and i'm going to
put them
in the fridge for 36 hours stay tuned
i promise this is going to be worth it
okay so these have been in
for pretty much two days now before you
guys say anything
i have two of these shirts these have
been resting for 36 hours it's time to
bake them
one two three
four five and six i'm excited because i
want to show you guys
why we put so much time and effort into
this so let's go bake these cookies
[Music]
so these are the finished products what
a two day cookie looks like
straight from the oven a lot of
interesting textures going on it's
almost like a landscape in like the
desert
where like the ground is kind of cracked
one last touch we're gonna do to really
take these to the next level
we're gonna use some flaky finishing sea
salt you can probably find this at any
grocery store
just like a nice steak i think seasoning
your cookies it sounds weird but
that's what i like to do i'm gonna go
make some vanilla milk okay so vanilla
milk
it's just a splash of vanilla just some
good old-fashioned milk and just to top
it off the splash of heavy cream
can really help take this to the next
level give it a nice little mix
and there you have it a two day brown
butter toffee
chocolate chip cookie with flaky sea
salt served
with vanilla milk these large pockets of
gooey chocolate that toffee that just
melts and adds flavor
i want you guys to see how it looks so
here we go
that's a damp cookie it is my favorite
version
of a chocolate chip cookie i think if
you have two days
so worth it
[Music]
i'm gonna go take a nap now so there you
have it a two minute
two hour and two day cookie if you have
any questions about the recipes feel
free to send me a message or drop a
comment below
i know that baking cookies can be pretty
tricky sometimes and i want to help you
guys the best i can
so good luck have fun and remember
there's always
time to bake until next time
you